it's getting closer we are now less than
a month
from election day anyone planning to
cast a ballot in nevada needs to be
registered to vote of course there are
certain deadlines to do that
including one that ends tomorrow a news
now reporter kristen drummond shows us
what voters need to know
mark your calendars for voter
registration dates each
voter registration method has a
different deadline
wayne thorley is deputy secretary of
state for elections
he says the first major deadline is
tuesday october 6.
that's the last day anyone can submit a
paper voter registration application
the form can be found online the dmv
county election
office or state agencies providing
public assistance
the paper allows anyone without a state
license or id
to register and vote in nevada you can
use the last four of your social
security number
for the identification field if you miss
the deadline
don't worry there are two other ways to
register going forward
on the secretary of state website or a
polling place
but state law requires a state license
or
id dmv has set up a
on saturdays in the morning appointments
for new residents only to obtain a
driver's license or id card
same day registration and early voting
starts october 17th
and finishes october 30th online
registration ends at midnight of october
29th
anyone with a nevada license or id can
also register november 3rd
election day but register soon to ensure
you receive a mail ballot
this year anybody who registers to vote
on
or before october 15th
will get a ballot sent to them in the
mail anybody that registers to vote
after october 15 must vote in person
different ways to guarantee you can cast
a ballot kristen drummond 8 news now
mail ballots are being sent to all
registered voters because of the
pandemic no one needs to request an
absentee ballot this year
clark county will start mailing the
ballots on october 10th